today europe is going through turbulent times
and more than ever it needs courageous
citizens it is important to
deepen peace, solidarity and mutual
respect it is
important to deepen not what
divides us but to deepen what
unites us i had the
chance in the vatican last friday
listening to pope francis so he asked what
happened to europe
the passport said we
should you should turn back to the founding fathers
of europe it is time to fight for europe
all europeans in
this model of transnational
democracy as the best  model for
securing cohesion and peace
faith are called to stand up and
no longer remain silent